had happened over that period so while
some things had failed to be followed
through it was a failure in part rather
than in whole when you say that the
system had not taken the lessons in
terms of Effectiveness in fact the
system was very very regularly tested in
reality
including to a very major extent in
February of 2020 and demonstrated that
it was very effective in dealing with
real life civil emergencies are in Wales
so while I don't descend at all from
your general conclusion that there were
things that
ought to have been done and could have
been done that hadn't been done I think
to describe it entirely in those terms
is to overlook some of the things that
positively had happened and the
successful way in which the system in
Wales demonstrated its ability to
respond when real emergencies are old
let me make it absolutely plain Mr
drayford it forms no part of this
examination to to question the
the remarkable individual response of
course with all those who responded in
the face of the pandemic and of course
it's quite plain that the Welsh
government was able
to material in material regard to
respond efficiently to the to the
terrible demands made on it
but the fact that it was able to respond
is neither here nor there in terms of
the consideration of whether or not it's
structurally the system of preparedness
in advance of the pandemic
was simply not as good as it should have
been and therefore the Welsh government
was not as prepared as it could have
been
would you agree up but like that I would
agree yes right
could I now ask you please and questions
about links to the United Kingdom
um a ministerial and medical level
the Hein review in July 2010 made a
multitude of recommendations
about how health ministers should meet
pan UK in order to address matters of of
mutual concern was it your experience
that at that level the health Minister
level the relations with between Wales
and the Westminster government worked
well
uh no I wouldn't uh characterize them as
working well or why they what they
lacked uh was a systematic basis for
engagement
and this has long been my complaint
about intermittent intergovernmental
relations in the United Kingdom that
they rely
far too often on individual willingness
to work in that way whereas what you
need is a robust system of Machinery of
government that brings people to the
table for common purposes whether
individuals are so inclined or not
you've referred then expressly to
ministers I was actually asking you
about
I was asking you about the at the health
level
does what you say apply therefore to not
to all forms of Welsh ministers so the
first Minister Health ministers and
other ministers
or does it also apply to the health
official level so for example relations
between the chief medical officers
artificial level much work goes on day
in day out in a perfectly orderly and
engaged uh way and I think you've got
good examples in the way the chief
medical officers at that top of the
profession uh level work together as
well I was trying to explain my
long-held view that the United Kingdom
Lacks at that ministerial
intergovernmental level a sufficiently
robust reliable regular
pattern of Engagement that does not rely
on the individual pre-elections of
particular players either to become
engaged or not to become engaged
in effect A system that doesn't rely on
ministerial whim as to whether or not a
meeting will take place at all
well I I would give you a good example
if I could when I became the Finance
Minister I took a telephone call at his
initiative from the chancellor of the
extractor Philip Hammond at the time
uh we agreed that day to day the
relationships would be between myself
and the chief secretary to the treasury
but he made it clear in that call that
at any point if I needed to speak
directly to him about an issue he would
always be available to take that call
that is a good example of where a
particular minister with a predilection
to cooperate in that way made it clear
that he wanted to do so the system ought
not to rely on individual willingness of
that sort
there is evidence to suggest that
consideration was given at some stage to
the setting up of a health Minister's
Forum to provide a structure of the type
that you've described do you know why
that never came to pass uh well there is
a JMC mechanism The Joint ministerial
committee mechanism it operated very
well in certain contexts it didn't
operate at all in others he didn't
operate in the health context and during
the time that I was the health minister
in Wales
while we enjoyed I would say very good
relationships with Jane Ellison who was
a conservative minister in charge of
public health and who led the Ebola
response
that was absent at the level of the
Secretary of State the JMC system has
always existed and it may or may not
operate effectively depending on perhaps
the whim of the contributors but I'm
asking about a particular body of Health
Minister's Forum which
was debated after the Hein review in
2010. do you know what became of those
proposals or or why
nothing in practice
I would say there was no appetite uh no
part of the UK government ministers to
establish such reform the initiative
lies with them in the JMC context right
so it wasn't a lack of initiative on the
on the Welsh party the the lay on the UK
side you believe under the JMC mechanism
the initiative lies in the hands of UK
ministers
there has since been a review of
intergovernmental relations it took
place in 2022
I think it was commissioned in 2018 so
it didn't proceed terribly quickly do
you know whether or not as first
Minister there have been any meetings of
the interministerial groups or the
standing committee or the Secretariat
for which that new process provides
it is a three-tiered structure its
Pinnacle is a council of ministers
that's the first ministers and the Prime
Minister it has met once but not in full
form because there has not been a first
minister of the Northern Ireland
executive since the agreement was struck
but the current prime minister Mr Sunnah
khaz presided over one meeting of the
council
are the intermediate tier has the Fisk
the finance interministerial committee
that does meet regularly and then it has
another standing committee that has met
more intermittently and another third
tier they will be the sort of meeting
between specific portfolio ministers
Health ministers for example could be
one uh I I myself do not believe that
that tier has operated in the way that
the intergovernmental review mechanism
anticipated it has been at best hit and
miss is that because health is such a
party political issue why do you think
Mr Rutherford um
why doesn't the
and my own View is that where they were
pre-existing relationships they have
continued so there's always been a
strong interministerial group around
farming and environment and Rural
Affairs and that has continued to meet
under the new regime and to do so
regularly where there is no history of
Engagement of that sort the new
Machinery has not succeeded in
sparking those arrangements into life so
I don't think it's particularly to do
with health or the politically contested
nature of Health I think there's no
history of it in health and as in other
parts of Whitehall where there is no
history
the new intergovernmental
Arrangements haven't succeeded in
generating new forms of interaction
it does appear however to be an
improvement on what went before
it is systematic it has an independent
Secretariat it has an independent means
of resolving disputes all of those are
improvements I was glad to be able to
sign the document good
there is also in the field of resilience
a a new Forum the UK resilience forum
in relation to which the Deputy Prime
Minister Oliver Darden gave evidence now
some time ago
um there have been three meetings of
that UK resilience Forum the Welsh
government attended the first one in
July 2021
and attended the third one in February
2023 but was absent with apologies from
the May 2022
meeting do you happen to know why
unusually the Welsh government
given the attendance of other entities
um absented itself from that meeting
I think it's important to say that while
it is ministerially chaired that form it
is not a ministerial meeting no indeed
not the Welsh government is represented
by senior officials I have made
inquiries as to why we were not
represented uh that day alongside uh
almost a dozen other bodies and the
information I received was that our
officials felt that the agenda that day
was an agenda in which they were already
engaging other forums and that on that
day couldn't command a priority in uh in
their Diaries but as you say they were
at the first and the third meetings and
it's Our intention to continue to be
involved if all these bilateral or
multilateral meetings or fora to work
then of course it requires the
participation of all the parties and
effort to be made to attend I'm sure
you'd agree with that I do
the final topic Mr Drakeford concerns
inequalities
there is evidence that the Welsh
government
has
devoted a great deal of time and energy
to ensuring
an improvement in prospects
economically
societally
on the part of its citizens and its
communities
it does nevertheless appear that in the
field of pandemic preparedness civil
emergency planning very little attention
was given to the issue of how a pandemic
would affect sectors of the community
disproportionately and how steps could
be taken to ensure that the impact
on those who are vulnerable and
marginalized could be mitigated would
you agree and I should say that it is a
a flaw that is apparent
from the analogous
people's guidance Doctrine strategies in
in Scotland and in
well I should say at the outset that
addressing inequalities is absolutely in
the bloodstream of successive Welsh
governments I spent a great deal of my
time in the very first uh assembly term
working with profita with Professor
Peter Townsend Who was the probably the
world's leading expert on health
inequalities at the time to get his
advice to address those issues in Wales
I think there is evidence you will have
seen from Dr Sandifer who's given
evidence
and the advice of Public Health Wales to
us was but while you had to be aware of
the unequal impact of a pandemic on the
population
it was very difficult to anticipate in
advance of the particular nature of that
pandemic where those inequalities would
most fall so while there is evidence in
the documentation of awareness of
inequality and the way in which a
pandemic would
exaggerate existing inequalities and
therefore had to be planned for from the
outset
the more granular planning which groups
would be affected how would you respond
to them you'd have to do that when the
nature of the pandemic you were dealing
with became more apparent you just
wouldn't be possible to plan without
that greater knowledge I think that that
was the advice that public health whales
would have given to us and I think has
given to the inquiry
thank you Mr Eve
Milady those are all my questions
um I believe you've granted permission
to covid-19 breed families for justice
Camry to us five minutes worth of
additional questions Miss Heaven thank
you milady
first Minister my name is Kirsten Haven
as I think you know I represent the
breathed families for justice Camry I
just want to ask you really about one
very small topic around some discussions
in 2013 but before we get there can I
please clarify some things from your
statements about some of the jobs and
political roles you've held so what you
tell us in your statements is from 2000
you became a special advisor for health
and social policy I think that was to
rodery Morgan and I think at that time
you had some experience of the SARS
outbreak is that correct that is
and we know obviously that you were
elected in 2011 can I just ask where
were you
um politically in 2009 when swine flu
broke out I was still a special advisor
to the Welsh government were you a
special advisor in a health role still
at that time or were you in a different
role I was the head of the first
Minister's political office at that time
but would it be fair to say you knew
about the fact of swine flu Oh I I did
and I attended in that advisory capacity
a number of meetings between Scottish UK
Welsh and Northern Irish ministers
2011 to 2013 we know that you were the
chair of the Welsh assembly Health and
Social care committee we also know
obviously that there was a MERS outbreak
um in April 2012.
did that come up when you were chairing
the committee at all do you recollect it
would only have come up in this way that
uh I think from recollection once a term
so 3 or three times a year
a minister responsible would appear in
front of the committee for what is
called General scrutiny in which any
topic of the day could be raised on the
minister asked questions that would have
been the opportunity for the committee
to cure on that matter but you recollect
whether or not that happened without
looking back I can't recollect here but
did you know that there had been such a
thing called MERS
either then or later when you became
minister of Health I would have been
aware of it yes and you also say in your
statement that you had experience of
Ebola and you've mentioned that briefly
today and I think that was when you were
a health minister is that fair and just
to be clear you became sorry I've been
asked to ask you to slow down sorry I
know I know you're trying to keep the
time to get through don't worry I'll
I'll let you I'll let you off as you run
over if you slow down I will sorry I'm
just just trying to stick to the time
yeah to be clear March 2013 was I think
when you became elected Minister for
health is that right correct
So Yesterday Frank Atherton was taken to
some minutes
um from the health emergency
preparedness unit so that's hepu for
short
and these related to a pandemic planning
yearly Conference in October 2013 they
were chaired by David Goulding who was
head of hepu
now there's no suggestion just to be
clear that you were at this conference
and we know that hepu sits within the
Health and Social Services Group and it
reports to the Welsh government
so by the stage of October 2013 I think
you'd been in post for seven months
is it safe to assume that by this stage
you knew about the fact that hepu
existed and the general nature of its
work
I would have known Mr Goulding prior to
becoming the health Melissa so I would
have been aware of his work and the unit
now what's interesting about this 2013
conference is we can see that a talk was
given by somebody called a Doctor John
Watkins and I won't bring it up just to
save time but I'll summarize the gist of
what I want to ask you about now we
understand he's a consultant or he was
there and a consultant epidemiologist in
public health Wales
and he is telling this conference about
how current threats include a novel
virus
and he says that that pandemic that
pandemic influenza planning assumptions
in Wales must consider that Wales could
see the emergence of such a novel virus
and he talks about little background
immunity
that a vaccine may not work or it may
not be available
there's then a reference to virulence
and transmissibility in the context of
the 1918 Spanish flu and there's also a
reference to swine flu
so in other words he's talking about
virulence and transmissibility with the
potential for fast transmission and a
very high death rate
now as I said you you're not at this
meeting we know that
but given that there's no reference in
your witness statement to hepoo or this
specific meeting or the gist of this
information
is it safe for us to assume that you
were not aware that these matters were
being discussed either in this
conference or in general terms and
that's in relation to a novel virus or a
disease X as it's been referred to in
this inquiry would that be a fair
assumption
I think it would
be fair I was aware of the conference
I've seen Dr Watkins the report of Dr
watkins's contribution since but I don't
think I would be likely to have been
alerted to it at the time so in other
words you were not briefed
not on the contribution of a single
speaker at a single conference and I
wouldn't expect to be no but just
thinking generally about your state of
knowledge on this obviously you'll
appreciate why I'm asking it's a very
important topic novel virus disease X
it's being talked about as a possible
risk in 2013 in Wales
and we obviously know that you went on
to become first Minister for Wales you
went on to chair the Welsh resilience
forum
did you as either a health minister or
even in your capacity as first Minister
for Wales specifically ask your
officials be it David Goulding or
somebody in public health Wales about
the risk of a novel virus or a disease X
breaking out in Wales and whether Wales
was prepared so did you ask that
question of anybody no
no giving you a long experience in
health and given what you had seen of
the dangerous viruses that I've set out
would you not accept a day that that was
an obvious and basic question that you
couldn't should have asked
I don't think I would accept it on those
terms because I would have asked myself
uh what sort of answer I would likely to
have received other than to recognize
that there are a plethora of
unknowns out there that you need to be
aware of
and that you need to have sources of
information about and I doubt that the
answer would have gotten me much further
than that but but the point is you
didn't ask the question did you
forgetting what the answer might have
been you didn't ask the question
I didn't ask the question you said to me
that was not a reasonable thing to have
done and I was explaining trying to
explain why I didn't ask the question
well those are all my questions thank
you very much first Minister thank you
thank you very much Miss heaven
Milady that concludes the evidence for
today thank you very much indeed indeed
a joke and uh next time we meet I think
we'll be in Wales excellent thank you
thank your time thank you